perhaps the biggest nightmares
Industrial Revolution the displacement
of millions of workers the loss of
huge numbers
it's funny because everybody's like oh
robots are sitting all jobs and I'm like
no humans have been doing robot jobs
it's tragic that we're having humans
both from such basic dioces all day I
think humans have such capabilities that
they should be resilient for
high value things that only humans can
do if a machine can do it then the
machine should do it so I think that's
what's going to happen just spend your
entire day in Flow State and do whatever
you do best and then a machine should
take care of all the vegetable work
around that
software engineer Flo cravello is the
founder and CEO of Lindy which is part
of the new artificial intelligence Gold
Rush that could upend the U.S labor
market to better understand how that
disruption will play out it's worth
looking at how the intersection of
computing and Telecommunications have
already impacted how Americans spend
their working hours AI furthers what the
venture capitalist Mark Andreessen has
described as software eating the world
even as the number of employed Americans
grew by 16 percent from 2000 to 2021
people working as executive secretaries
and executive administrative assistants
fell by 66 percent because of tools like
voicemail calendar apps web browsers and
dictation software Lindy could drive
that number down even further by
creating an AI personal secretary that
can book travel take notes during
meetings and handle basic email
correspondence the long-term vision is
to basically automate all knowledge work
so we really think of her as an AI
employee of sorts over the same time
period as the overall labor market grew
the number of travel agents plummeted by
70 thinks in part to direct to Consumer
booking sites now tools like trip notes
AI can build a full travel itinerary
without the hassle of price matching or
spending hours reading up on whether the
ancient Athens tour or the gourmet food
tasting are the better use of an
afternoon the number of professional
photographers in the US has fallen by 41
since 2000 because of smartphones and
ubiquitous digital camera cameras now
startups like headshot Pro could drive
that down with its AI generated
professional headshots such as this one
which cost me 29 versus the roughly 700
that it cost to hire a human
photographer here where I live in
Washington DC AI tools that already
exists could automate 25 of the tasks
American workers do according to a
recent report by Goldman Sachs which
will free up humans to do other things
the prediction that AI will put us all
out of work is based on a fallacy and we
can expect total employment to continue
Rising even as technology wipes out
specific jobs it's a process of creative
destruction to use the phrase of the
economist Joseph schumpeter which
explains why a whole new Industries
emerge following The Disappearance of
ice Cutters blacksmiths harness makers
wheel rights ditch diggers Weavers
holographists pin Setters lamplighters
elevator operators collectors block
Keepers projectionists Milkman and log
drivers in the process we became
profoundly richer technology frees up
resources to create jobs that people in
the past could never have imagined and
no this time is not different people
mistakenly believe that there is a fixed
amount of work to be performed into the
academy the reality of it is that human
needs and wants are infinite the
lifestyle that you and I live is
actually better than the lifestyle of
Louis XVI and we still want more in the
beginning of the 1900s something like 90
of the active population World dominance
since then we went down and very quickly
to five percent of the active population
or something like that and yet we don't
have mass unemployment very far from it
in the US
since 2000 Factory automation has driven
down manufacturing employment even
though the U.S is producing more stuff
than ever before on the other side of
the Ledger software development has been
one of the fastest growing professions
since 2000 increasing by a hundred and
forty three percent and outpacing the
growth of overall employment
that Trend will probably continue AI
won't replace coders but it will make it
possible for the less technically
sophisticated to draft more
sophisticated applications and this will
enable Founders to bootstrap an idea
with minimal backing similar to how
cloud computing enabled Tech startups to
bring their products to Market without
their own back-end infrastructure
crevello predicts that there will be
demand for software applications to fit
every conceivable need as the economy
moves toward more personalized
everything when you ask something to
Lindy the way she performs the tax
actually is that she writes a little
piece of code to perform the tasks for
you for example if you say hey help you
find still diminished with love next
week she's going to ride a piece of food
to be like I'm going to look at your
calendar I'm going to put availabilities
I'm going to compile them in an email
I'm going to send them to Bob and I'm
going to wait for everybody so all of
that is a mini piece of food and I think
that's amazingly interesting because I
always compare it to the Industrial
Revolution where it's like default the
Industrial Revolution certain Goods like
capsule fans were very expensive one Gap
was probably of the order of like 100 or
500 right and After the Revolution these
Goods became so cheap that we started to
have single used versions of them
and so you know we have like the red
Solo cups and like the big pens and
they're just so cheap that you can't
even refill a big bang it's just cheaper
to buy a new one than replace the ink
and so here it's the same thing
historically code has been very
expensive what app has cost of the order
of ten thousand dollars to one hundred
thousand dollars this is the AI
cognitive Revolution code is becoming so
cheap that it can be disposable in
single use and so it cuts of the order
of one cent to build an application and
so effectively you're gonna live in a
world where bespoke mini applications
are built for every little use case that
you have throughout your day and that's
what it is doing effectively
if we think about generative AI right
now I can create a photo of you know
Gandalf wearing a pink shirt in a silly
hat in seconds Alex Banks writes the
newsletter through the noise and is the
co-founder of tribescaler a tool that
uses an AI algorithm to generate viral
social media hooks and all of these
creative tasks that were taking
Photoshop expert hours
I can now do with a very simple prompt
it is leveling the playing field for
Creative output where those who weren't
created those who couldn't tell stories
now can and those who were creative are
only getting even better I see AI as
on-demand intelligence right it's way
cheaper and way faster than what you can
get from humans just because tools like
Amber can generate tracks like this one
with a simple prompt of exciting
fast-paced and a little bit suspenseful
that doesn't mean that AI will put the
nearly 10 000 Americans working as music
directors and composers out of a job
rather it'll mean a lot more
individually tailored music tools like
Amber will do some of the work but it
will help composers work faster better
and free them up for higher level tasks
radio GPT can pick songs write scripts
and have a realistic sounding voice read
it but the demand for human curated
music won't disappear the internet
destroyed album sales which were once a
major source of Revenue but the number
of professional musicians has still
grown by 76 percent since 2000. Banks
and crevello are working on systems that
utilize gpt4 and artificial intelligence
to do things that a generation ago would
have been unimaginable the
century so try scale in itself helps you
go right on Twitter right it's your AI
writing assistant and personal
collaborator we use gbt4 in really two
settings number one is to help you write
a great hook so a hook is the number one
factor in whether your piece of content
succeeds or sits in the dark and so the
hook is that absolute critical factor
and so we use gpt4 with fine tune
prompts to use vetted viral structures
to help you write better Banks is also
currently working on a project called
Eloy which he thinks will improve on
note-taking applications that are being
marketed as a second brain if we look at
notion it
wonderful platform
store all of your personal knowledge and
it's fairly good at retrieving with some
search it does a fairly good job but it
isn't it isn't entirely robust and then
you have other platforms right on that
capture phase such as say things three
that is a wonderful quick capture tool
on the desktop where
I can hit control spacebar and I could
immediately capture a thought but then
it's stored in a central repository and
it's up to me to relocate that thought
what we're doing with alloy is we're
essentially going okay how can we
complete that cycle for an individual
and build a second brand for you so that
you can access your creativity on demand
if I'm here and I'm wanting to write a
tweet say and six months ago I had a
conversation with my friend Natalie and
we were chatting about Ai and there was
a wonderful Insight that I got from that
conversation and I added it to my second
break all on gpt3 and it's and it's
history now when I go to write that
tweet and I start to write about gpt3
all of a sudden what Elon can do is it
could resurface that idea for you
dynamically how we think about how
that's going to propel productivity is
really really vast and something that
I'm massively excited for
change is scary I think we all about to
see maybe the biggest change in human
history
that sounds like hyperbole but I really
believe that I I people love comparing
AI to smartphones or the internet I
think it's Larry Samuels who said it
it's vegetables up to the invention of
Fire or the wheel though the Goldman
Sachs report predicts that 30 of
Industries won't be impacted by AI at
all some of these tools will free up
human labor for service occupations like
that of food which hasn't been
fundamentally altered by Computing and
has grown nearly 37 since 2000 outpacing
the growth of overall employment the
same goes for taxi drivers and personal
trainers
as cravella points out we are hoarding
too much human labor in existing
Industries especially those controlled
by the public sector for example the
federal government wants to hire 87 000
new IRS agents when those same people
could be reducing goods and services
that other humans actually value
Healthcare administrators have grown in
numbers since 2000 partly because of all
the red tape that came with Obamacare
technology might have already started
shrinking the education labor force and
new tools like course AI that can design
syllabi or cogni which offers one-on-one
AI tutoring we'll drive further
productivity gains in the sector
remaking how we work is a core part of
every Tech Revolution and it's through
this process that we've profoundly
driven up our standard of living let the
robots have their jobs